when derek stevens came up with the idea
for circa he wanted to be a mecca
for sports fans and for sports gamblers
we have hector mejia live now at
what is the biggest sports book in las
vegas checking out another interesting
aspect of this property
hector hey there john this is really
exciting and according to derek stevens
las vegas is doing more than just
reinventing itself he says this is
really ushering
a whole new era not only for a city but
for the entire state and we're actually
inside
a brand new broadcast studio for vsan
the gambling network and joining us live
we have brian musberger
to explain you know what you guys will
be doing out here
so we're we're thrilled to have new
studios here at circa
which is the largest sports book in the
world and sort of the epicenter of
sports betting in the united states
so we'll we'll have our studios going uh
doing 20 hours of live linear
programming a day out of 20 hours from
here that's right so we're thrilled to
get going
we'll start off with mitch and paul
who've been on uh
been out here in las vegas for a long
time they'll start off at 4 a.m tomorrow
so this is exciting let's talk about the
outlook for sports betting while we
enjoy the view back here we have the
sports book here
three stories tall right behind us well
people in las vegas know
that sports betting just enhances the
sports
viewing experience and the rest of the
country is just learning that but this
what derek's built here changes
everything this becomes a pilgrimage
that every sports fan is going to have
to take it it's
there's nothing like it anywhere in the
united states for viewing
for for watching games you and i were
talking about this uh briefly just a few
minutes ago
are fewer people placing bets right now
with everything going on or what's your
perspective as an insider
now with the proliferation of mobile
betting it's sort of the perfect
pandemic activity you can stay at home
and
and fire away on on your mobile app and
watch the games and and
socially distance so uh no sports
betting is not slowing down anytime soon
ryan and you're also telling me that
this is sort of uh going to be the
epicenter for
sports betting across the country and
possibly the world
it is derek opens a lot of the markets
here
and uh what what circus sports does
uh especially in college sports uh
they really they set the lines that
everybody else follows so for us as a
as the cnbc of sports betting to be in
the in in the middle of all the action
we were able to give great insight
to viewers and and to followers very
lastly any advice for those first-time
sports bettors there's a lot to learn
and the lessons are expensive
so do your research yeah we get a free
lesson
no one gets a free lesson in sports
wedding all right thank you so the
property again opens tonight at midnight
21 and over only
and we're broadcasting from the brand
new beeson broadcast studios
right next to the brand new sports book
three stories tall
right behind us reporting live hector
mejia alex let's send it back over to
you
he's like y'all can't afford the lessons
you gotta figure it out